we have to be here it's quarter to eight
in about ten minutes from CERN there's
going to be a press conference actually
a seminar first the belief is the
feeling is that they're going to
announce the discovery of a new particle
yeah maybe the Higgs
I haven't heard that the evidence that
was presented back in December has
disappeared so but it's still officially
a secret yeah so Higgs Higgs will should
be there he's he's one of those who have
been invited and yeah I think he'll be
there he's in his eighties now but the
oldest work was done in around 1964 so
it's going on for 50 years ago it's a
long time 48 years ago this work was
published so they've been waiting a long
time we've all been waiting a long time
for maybe this today that's worrying
away I wonder how many thousands of
people huh I'm a bit nervous about this
fit really because in December these
were really technical seminars and in
fact it was quite difficult to pick out
where they were saying look this is this
is potential evidence but on this
occasion given the worldwide publicity
they must at some stage say we think we
found something new they must unless
they haven't there is that's pretty
Hicks yeah I was at summer school in
1985 in Edinburgh and someone and up on
the blackboard as Peter Higgs came into
everything they'd drawn a picture and
they'd put image of Peter Higgs his face
and they put a Superman cape but they
called the SH super Higgs
please
so I think what they will have is two
seminars one by there are two men
detectors which which are built to
discover the Higgs one's called appleís
and of course one's called CMS as we
know like a school boy in a candy shop
and then we're people commented wow this
is there is the detector so the
spokesperson for CMS is gonna give a
seminar I think there'll be about 20
minutes 25 minutes and he'll review the
data up to a given signal the size of
the standard model can you explain to me
the difference between a Higgs field in
a Higgs boson
yeah the Higgs field is a field is just
something that has a value and it's got
a value everywhere idea and the the the
Higgs is that acordes it's got it it
doesn't have a direction it just has a
value it's got some value here and some
value there if you excite an
electromagnetic field you'll create a
photon and we all happily see that
coming down to us now the equivalent for
the Higgs field is if you excite the
Higgs field you will create a Higgs
boson of a particle and that's what's
being detected it's the excitation of
the Higgs field which in turn requires a
lot of energy that's why you have to
fire the protons in so the idea is you
smek the protons together those protons
then that energy in that in that regime
can be enough to excite the Higgs field
which is permeating the whole universe
in that regime excites the higgs field
and then that can generate a Higgs
particle which will then decay almost
instantaneously and it's got these
because it can couple to all the
particles in the universe it can decay
in a whole set of ways different ways
some of them via creating photons others
by creating the W and Z part
others by decaying into quarks so and
those are the channels and the the ones
that they've been able to get the best
statistics on are the ones where the
Higgs decays into the two photons and
the ones where the Higgs decays into the
four leptons plus or minus 0.6 GV at 4.9
standard deviations thank you it says
the punchline to the last slide when we
excite the electromagnetic field and get
a photon that photon seems to last a
very long time it can travel across the
universe how come when we excite the
higgs field and create a Higgs boson
this thing vanishes so quickly so a
photon is massless and it's so it's got
it it doesn't have anything to decay
into the Higgs particle is a very very
massive particle it's got a mass of
about a hundred and if this is correct
today a mass of about 133 times that of
a proton which we also think of a fairly
as a massive particle and because it can
be it can interact with so many other
particles with lower masses it can decay
so it doesn't want to hang around it's
this massive thing that's just feeling a
bit you know it can't move very far and
so just decay is based on its surface
until this morning this will last five
minutes so there seem to be having a
best-fit Valiant
about 126 points five g's sure that's
slightly different so far from one so
the key number that they've been giving
is that what they think of the mass of
this particle is they're not calling it
the Higgs they've been getting the mass
of it and the mass they've given in
terms of a unit called Giga electron
volts and the electron volt is an energy
it's the energy required to lift an
electron through one vault in terms of
joules that's about 10 to the minus 19
joules it's very small a Giga electron
volt is a billion electron volts the
mass scales that they're finding is
about 125 GeV that's what the the mass
that was being given by CMS and at about
126 GeV being given by Atlas so
something to compare it with a proton
which makes up you and I has a mass of
around 1 GeV so this is a back fact just
a bit less than a GV so this is about
130 times the mass of a proton so it's
it's effectively you know if you think
of an atom an atom a heavy atom which is
made up of say 50 protons and 50
neutrons or something this is about that
mass right is this that's one particle
it was one piece
yeah that guy gonna get a no vote for us
and I think he is that's pizza Higgs
I think he was crying
I must be quite an emotional time for
him it's on a teaching basis it's
fantastic you'll be able to now say this
is the complete picture of the standard
model however let me put in one caveat
here which is what they haven't been
able to demonstrate and which is why I
think they're not yet saying this is the
Standard Model Higgs is is it the
Standard Model Higgs or is it actually a
more complicated object that maybe that
is this part of it looks like the
standard model but there are other bits
that might yet sure that's the director
general of CERN
good stuff good stuff